bonjour je m'appelle morgan je suis hors
les années j'étais responsable
informatique
il y a encore peu de temps aujourd'hui
j'ouvre un escape game avec la plus
grande franchise de france dans l'hyper
centre d'orléans ça faisait 12 ans que
j'étais dans le milieu informatique et
je souhaitais développer ma propre
activité
j'étais férus des scripts game j'en ai
fait plusieurs et en france et à
l'étranger et je me suis dit pourquoi
pas en ouvrir un afin de promouvoir
l'ouverture du futur escape game et
sculpture self orléans je souhaitais
apporter quelque chose de plus l'idée la
réalité augmentée m'est venue du fait de
pokémon go et le scénario tout
simplement parce que ben je pense
qu'avec l'histoire de jeanne d'arc
il ya beaucoup à dire il ya beaucoup à
faire ga que les joueurs découvrent un
peu autrement la ville d'orléans et
l'histoire de jeanne d'arc
donc comment jouer tout simplement en
allant sur le site internet et sculpture
self orléans point fr de là vous allez
pouvoir réserver votre parcours à partir
du week-end du 14 juillet vous allez
pouvoir télécharger une application et
cette application va vous permettre de
scanner des marqueurs qui se sont
positionnés un peu partout dans la ville
d'orléans dans l'hyper centre et du coup
vous allez pouvoir en scannant depuis
cette application s'est dit marqueur
voir des objets en 3d
écoutez de l'audio et où voir des vidéos
et répondre à différentes énigmes
pourquoi avoir proposé ce grand parcours
urbain et c'est que c'est totalement
innovant des des chasses aux trésors ça
existe mais là c'est quand même
différent on retrouve l'univers des x
games c'est quand même des énigmes à
résoudre et sur un support totalement
inédit totalement novateur qui est la
réalité augmentée ça va en contraste
avec le fait que à l'escem games vous
aurez
des salles de dernière génération et
vous pourrez du coup avoir vraiment de
façon différente de jouer à un escape
game de répondre à des énigmes 1,10
plutôt classique les escape game et un
autre totalement novateur qui est en
dehors et en réalité au but
il y aura trois salles pour commencer
trois salles pour deux scénarios il y
aura deux salles avec le même scénario
et ce scénario sera d'ailleurs unique
dans la franchise et sculpture self sera
vraiment créé pour pour orléans pour
l'ouverture orléanaise n'hésitez pas à
venir tester soit le parcours soit les
salles proposé j'ai hâte de vous
rencontrer